[Music]
if you look at our current technological
systems they're obviously nowhere near
where our minds are they're very
different and one of the biggest
questions for me is what's the
difference between where we are now and
where we need to be if you want to build
mines if you want to build systems that
are generally intelligent and
self-motivated and maybe self-aware and
of course the answer to this we don't
know because if he knew we already done
it but there are basically several
perspectives on this one is our minds as
general learning systems that are able
to model arbitrary things including
themselves and if they are this they
probably need a very distinct set of
motivations needs things that they want
to do and I think that humans get their
specifics due to their particular needs
we have cognitive and social and
physiological needs and they turn as an
who we are our motivations determine
what where we put our attention to and
what we learn and what we actually do in
the world what we model how about we
perceive what are you conscious of and
in a similar sense it might be that it's
sufficient to build a general learning
architecture and combine this there's a
good motivational system and we are not
there yet that we've built a general
learning architecture for instance our
minds can learn and create new
algorithms they can be used to write
code and invent code programming code
for instance or the rules that you need
to build a shop and run that shop if you
are a shopkeeper which is some kind of
programming task and its own right we
don't know how to build a system that is
able to do this yet it involves for
instance that we have systems that are
able to learn loops and we have some
techniques to do this for instance a
long short term memory and a few other
tricks but they're nowhere near of what
people can do so far and it's not quite
clear how much work needs to be done to
extend these systems and to what people
can do it could be that it's very simple
it could be that it's going to take a
lot of research the dire view is what's
more the traditional view is that human
minds have a lot of also in our
complexity that we need to build a lot
of functionality into it like an Minsky
society of mind to get to all the tricks
that people are up to and if that is the
case then it might take a very long time
and we have created all these different
functional mechanisms but I don't think
that it's going to be so dire because
our genome is very short and most of
that codes for a single cell very little
of it codes for the brain and I think a
cell is much more complicated than a
brain a brain is probably largely
self-organizing and built not like
clockwork
but like a cappuccino so you mix the
right ingredients and then you let it
percolate and then forms a particular
kind of structure so I do think because
nature pulls it off pretty well in most
of the cases that even though brain
probably needs more complexity than a
cappuccino dramatically more it's going
to be much simpler than building a very
complicated machine like a cell
[Music]